hey everybody it's Mike frer here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week today we're talking about cmmc
control acl2
d314 route remote access via managed
access control points you know whatever
those
[Music]
are so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and
alone depressed
and sad trying to understand all this
cmmc def fars and nist SP sp800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
crushing workload I've got good news
great news in fact it says great news
right there not good news it's better
than good it's great I got great news
you found your home here at on call
compliance solution we can help you
transform into your company's on call
compliance hero and make compliance suck
less that's what we do let's jump into
it so so in cmmc control ac.
l231 14 route remote access via managed
access control points is all about
controlling traffic right got the
traffic controllers out trying to bring
some planes in trying to get some planes
out that's what we're doing and also
having it documented for the purpose of
compliance system architecture
considerations like best practices Etc
when they say managed access control
points an example of what in the world
they're talking about is uh things like
refer referring to routing external
traffic through a firewall uh or a VPN
or a wireless access point in order to
manage and control the traffic along
with verifying the identity uh and then
logging what they are doing through your
seam solution uh and you know if you're
not familiar with the seam solution it's
a security information and event
management system that's what they're
doing now if I'm an assessor and I'm
looking at this control I'm trying to
figure out if you're compliant there's
two points I'm looking at Point number
one determine if managed access control
points are identified and implemented
so what would I do for a sample answer I
would say managed access control points
are identified as VPN and secure
verified access to the Azure government
environment access control is
implemented via active directory and MFA
so again just depends on what systems
you're using if you're using Office 365
gcci there's an answer in there for you
if you got on Prem there an answer in
there for you you might even bring up
firewalls and vpns and things like that
uh but again the the the idea is are
they implemented yes are they identified
we also might look at our Network
documentation are they identified on a
network diagram or cui flow control all
of those things are very important now
second thing I would assess for
determine if remote access is routed
through manag network access control
points so maybe we say no remote access
is possible without being routed through
the organization's VPN a all right can't
get to the cui unless we're routing
through that managed Access Control
point of the VPN or maybe if you got
Office 365 GCC High we're looking at
Azure government access including
requirements to for ad or active
directory and multiactor authentication
so again lots of ways to determine if
the remote access is actually routed
through those manage access control
points now if you're a defense
contractor and you're struggling to
figure this out we can help because at
on call we work with defense contractors
just like you like you the guy that's
watching this video or the girl that's
watching this video yeah we work with
people just like you who have had this
defar nist itar and cmmc compliance
stuff dropped into their laps like a
seagull on a sunny day and we teach you
how to level up and be a proper on call
compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps great areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance as your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant You Are Not Alone
our compliance EXP are always on call
for you you can visit cmmc
compliance.com or check out the bio
below for links to get help right now if
you love the content we're putting out
here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance nerds roll it out until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe out there and secure and hit us in
the comments below to let us know what
you'd like to learn more about when it
comes to information security and
compliance and I'll see you on the next
one
w
[Music]